we start with breaking news on the
economy new figures from the office for
National statistics show inflation has
unexpectedly gone up to 10.4 percent in
February the Consumer Price Index or CPI
was expected to come down from January's
10.1 oh my goodness me how bad news is
that for the government girlfriend is
here hi good morning tell us more it's
it's a bit worrying for policy makers
economists were expecting inflation to
come down to 9.9 but we've had this
surprise leap in inflation to 10.4 now
this has just dropped so we don't know
exactly what's caused it but some of the
early signs suggest that it's food
inflation and restaurants and cafes that
have been driving this food inflation 18
I'm being told yeah yeah exactly well
that that wouldn't be a surprise it was
around 16 the previous month
um and crucially for the bank of England
this is way above where it was penciling
in inflation to be around this time of
the year which means that there's more
pressure now on the bank to raise
interest rates when policy makers meet
next week and of course there are other
worrying signs in the economy as well
the labor market although it's starting
to soften wages are still Rising pretty
robustly
um even though they are lagging behind
inflation and if wages rise too quickly
that could put pressure on
um on prices because businesses have to
raise their prices in order to protect
their profits and of course inflation is
also five times the bank of England's uh
two percent Target and although in
recent weeks and days Market
expectations of where interest rates
might end up have come down this
suggests that they might have to ratchet
them back up again just very quickly
what does this mean for our mortgages
well it means that as I just said that
interest rates might have to stay longer
for hire well which means will they go
higher still they could do so in recent
weeks and in recent days markets have
expected that interest rates might
actually
uh Peak at a much lower level than we
were expecting that the bank of England
might not actually even raise interest
rates when it meets next week but all of
this suggests that you may have to okay
for now thanks so much Dave thank you